hey welcome back to my channel my name
is samuel leeds and i am a property
investor
putting out videos on youtube every
single day i've been doing that for
years
but in this video right now i'm going to
be doing something very special which is
answering your property investment
questions so
listen if you've got any questions
around property investment around the
different strategies
about what's holding you back what's
stopping you then you can
comment your question your problem your
challenge below
and i will do my best to be your
property doctor and
fix your question problem challenge so
get commenting below
also before you do that do me a massive
favor and
smash the like button that'd be
absolutely awesome and then this these
types of videos
can be spread and seen by more potential
future property investors
my challenge and my mission is that as
many people will be able to invest in
property
the smart way to ultimately give them a
better quality of life
like property did for me and my
wonderful family as well
so smash the like button get commenting
your questions below
while i answer last week's um
questions and comments and while i'm
answering those feel free to just be
commenting along commenting
asking questions and i'll be answering
your questions next week don't forget to
subscribe as well
otherwise i might answer your question
and you never even knew it happened
because you didn't get a notification
so subscribe and turn on the
notification bell that'd be amazing
so ibrah says i want to invest in
property and start rent to rent
but i'll be completely honest i
don't have a passion for property and
it's not something i love
do you still recommend going all out in
property
thanks for the videos you are an
inspiration
ibrah thank you so much it's crazy that
you watch my videos and see me as an
inspiration
but you actually don't really like
property that much where my entire
channel
is a property channel but what would my
boss do be
uh no i i personally probably wouldn't
recommend that you go all out in
property if you don't love property
because there's gonna be days
where things aren't going well you're
out viewing houses
agents are rejecting you the rain is
pouring down
tenants are being a pain and if you
don't love
creating homes for people and just the
bricks and mortar and the
the wheeling dealing and if you don't
just i'm addicted to property and
negotiating deals and providing
beautiful i love buildings i love
if you don't like it i probably would
say not to throw yourself
all in it however there's two different
types of what i do and what i teach
one is making money in property as a
business
i.e rent to rent and deal sourcing and
that's how you make money
and then the other is how you invest
money into property
what you could do ibra is i would say
find something you love
make money doing something you love and
then potentially
invest the profits into property but
where you don't have to get that
involved because it is an incredible
investment so
invest in it maybe make money in it rent
to rent i'd probably say not unless you
have a rekindle of love for property but
that's my opinion that's my advice i
don't know what you guys think in the
comments
what do you think of ibrah's question
let me know in the chat box hope to see
you do well
dude whether it's in property or
something else okay nathan
newbury great q a and samuel thank you
one from me
for next week would be when trying to
speak to letting agents
doing the due diligence about demand and
rental values rather than estate agents
in my potential area
i find a lot of the agents are
interlinked with each other
how do you how do i initially ensure you
get to the letting agent and not anybody
that's free on the day which could end
up being the sales team i felt like even
the letting agents just palm you off
onto the sales
team thumbs down um nathan
first thing i'll say is the sales team
should be able to tell you what you want
to know
you want to know all the information of
the product
of the house what's the rentability
what's the area
if they're selling that product all day
every day to prospective tenants
they should be able to know the demands
the good streets the bad streets the
amount of
so i love speaking to the sales team
no problems with that at all maybe
you're speaking to
a a junior member of staff that just
isn't experienced that just doesn't
understand
in which case i'd start i just ask them
the questions i just go look
i'd love to know a bit about this this
this this
what's what are the best streets how
much room would i get here what
and if they don't know the answers
they're going to feel awkward and
they're going to be like i'm not sure
let me find someone who knows i don't
see what the problem is maybe you've had
one or two bad experiences maybe but
generally speaking
or ring up and pretend to be a tenant
hey i'm looking at renting a three-bed
house in church road in
birmingham i just wondered roughly how
much a three bed would be around that
area
and they'll give you the information but
really you're thinking of buying a house
in that street
but you'll get so just keep calling
different people and and don't worry
about it just ask the questions and
it's not your job to determine whether
they're going to be qualified enough to
answer your questions
it's your job to just ask the questions
and then they have to find a way of
giving you the answers hope that helps
all right sam hawkins when refinancing
on the new value of a property do you
need to leave in 25 percent
for the new loan at the new value if so
does this need to be factored into brrs
as you'd still be leaving money in
so sam you wouldn't be leaving money in
because
i mean yeah you do need to leave money
yet no no bank
will lend you they used to when i
started in property 12 13 years ago
but right now in 2021 no bank is gonna
lend you a hundred percent of that uh
loan to value so if you're buying a
house for a hundred grand
they're not going to go here's 100 grand
they're going to want you to have some
skin in the game i.e 25
so they'll say we'll give you 75 but you
need to put in
25 which is why most people think they
need to save up 25 grand or whatever it
might be
to buy a house and what brr is brr is
where you say
here's what i'm going to do i'm going to
buy a really rundown house
a nasty house for 50 grand
and i'm gonna buy it with a loan
because you can buy it with a loan if
you're buying it cash you can buy it
with a loan
if you're getting a mortgage 75 you
can't get a loan for 25
they won't let you they're going no no
you need skin in the game whereas if
you're buying a house for cash
there's no mortgage so you could take
out a bridging loan of 30 grand
and then an angel investor a joint
venture partner
a personal loan a freaking credit card
no one cares 20 grand buy the house
then spend 10 grand 20 grand
doing the house up and now let's say
that the new value is 100 grand
when you then get 75 000 mortgage on the
new house
you're going to leave 25 in but that is
equity so you're gonna pull out 75 grand
but then you're going to pay yourself
back
because you've pushed so you will leave
none of your own money in and you'll pay
off all the cup debt the credit
card company whatever it is you'll pay
them all off and you'll replace that
debt with the new debt which is the
mortgage so
i hope that makes sense it takes a
little bit of getting your head around
um but when you get it oh it's amazing
okay well done sam hope to see you hope
to see you soon all right mr s
if i find a possible rent to rent but
it's within article 4
should i consider getting planning
permission is it worth it and what's the
process like
i wouldn't do that mr s because it's not
your house
i mean getting planning permission is a
process doing that on a house
just because you're going to have it on
a rent to rent and control it and make a
bit of money each month it's not worth
it
if you're trying to rent to rent in an
article 4 area
find existing tired hmos that have
already got planning permission but
they're just a bit run down
or run down student let's and then spend
a few grand turn them into luxury
professional let's but you've already
got planning permission in place and you
can find those on gumtree
open rent spare room and undone burning
desire
houses are going up and i feel we will
all be in negative equity as there will
be a crash soon
why don't you ever tell people the risks
um i've done many videos about the risks
of property investment about bad
builders bad tenants
like probably dozens and dozens of
videos about risks
i've also done dozens and dozens of
videos about what happens if there's a
crash
about what happens if you buy a property
and the market falls
and the answer is it doesn't matter as
long as you're making good cash flow
from the property if you buy a property
and it drops in value
so if you're making good money each
month from the rent
you buy it it drops so what it's an
asset
it's a goose it's a golden goose
that's every month laying you some nice
golden eggs
we call those eggs rent if the golden
goose
drops in value you don't care you're not
getting paid by the goose you're getting
you
the the eggs is the money and if
if the value of the house drops so what
just hold it and keep getting the eggs
keep having the
golden goose eggs and then wait for the
fire to go back up again
and then when it goes up refinance
release more equity and buy more houses
list mass could you please tell me
what's the minimum amount i have
i can have to buy a house
generally speaking as a first-time buyer
in the uk which is what you're talking
about
the minimum amount to buy a house so
you're probably talking to buy a house
minimum
what like 60 grand in some really cheap
parts of the country in the uk
generally speaking if you get much less
than that you're going to start
struggling to get a mortgage anyway
if it's 40 grand or less you're not
going to be able to get a mortgage so
50 60 grand is going to be as cheap as
you're going to buy
a nice little terraced house you're
getting 25
deposit so you're probably talking after
stamp duty
and legals and whatnot you're probably
talking about
15 20 grand minimum to buy a cheap buy
to let
it's not going to give you much return
you might make a couple hundred pound a
month but that's about as
little as as you could do if you're
buying a house to live in
it depends on where you want to live you
can put less of a deposit down
maybe you could put down just a 10 or 15
deposit if you're a first-time buyer
but then you've got to live there which
means that you're not going to be able
to get
any money each month because you're
living there but also
i mean you can buy a house without using
any of your money though if you find a
nice little house and you need 15 20
grand
well you could get a uh
a joint venture to put money in or an
angel investor and you could say look
the property's going to be given 20
return on investment so if you buy a
house for 50 grand and you rent it out
for 500 pounds
after all costs and everything that's
probably going to be giving you about 18
20 return on investment well
you could borrow the deposit 15 grand
off somebody
buy the house together they put the
money in and then you can split the
profits they're still getting a 10
return on their money but you're getting
a little bit of money each month
and you own part of the house and you
put no money in
so technically you don't need any money
to buy a house
but that obviously takes work all right
james james hi samuel what are the main
factors in predicting how high a house
will appreciate over a certain amount of
years
okay so there's a couple of ways to do
this james first way is looking at
history
if we look back at history over the last
100 years or more
we can see that generally speaking house
prices tend
to double in value every 10 years or so
so
if you buy a house generally speaking if
we look back over history
it's gonna it in 10 15 years it could
easily have doubled in value
now we don't know that for sure and we
can't say that that's gonna happen
um but you're saying how much it might
go up
another thing to do is to look at
different areas so if you are investing
in
let's say um liverpool and you're buying
a house in liverpool for 100 grand
but then five years ago in manchester
you could buy this like for like sort of
house on the outskirts of manchester for
100 grand and now that's gone up to 130
and now liverpool's beginning to trend
you could think well it might be similar
so you can look at what's going on in
the street you can look at ceiling
prices
ultimately you don't know capital
appreciation doesn't pay the bills
you cannot rely
on a house going up in value for you to
get paid
that's why i say if it drops it doesn't
matter you have to
see the increase as a bonus and you have
to rely on the monthly
rent or you have to force the value
up by doing a brr or a flip by buying a
property that's got a problem
fixing the problem and forcing the value
up people that buy houses and solely
just
say oh i'm just going to buy it and i'm
going to get paid when it goes up in
value and i'm just going to wait
it's not really very smart in my opinion
all right last question glenn kirkham
hey glenn what's happening brother he
says
who would win in an arm wrestle between
alistair and russell
i really do not know i would probably
put my money on russell because russell
is a little bit bigger and probably
maybe i don't know the stair looks quite
strong i don't know i'd probably say 50
50. what i will say is i think i would
win
against both of them not put together
but individually
maybe we should make it happen guys if
you enjoyed this video smash the like
button don't forget to put your comments
and questions
below in the comment box and uh
subscribe you can subscribe right up
here if you want to see more videos like
this you can check out our whole
playlist right here
you might also like this one too watch
the videos immerse yourself and go
get some results in property thanks so
much i'll see you next time